welcome back everybody it is
a beautiful friday afternoon
john and i are out here at the back of
our eight news now building and it is
our founders day and we are collecting
food for serving our kids foundation and
snack stuff that kids can get too easily
right yeah that's the idea serving our
kids wants snacks things that kids can
nosh on while they're you know causing
trouble and having some fun around so
it's crackers it's juice boxes things
like that you can see some of the things
that are very fruit cups fruit cups
would be great uh what do we got over
there sherry we got top ramen noodles
you got capri sun
juice packs applesauce oatmeal
and and the aviator he's got a cereal
bars
and applesauce we need you to come down
and donate we we had some great folks
already come in and make a difference
and we hope that you can do that too
yeah and we've been here all morning
we've had some great donations we see
the aviator behind us let me see we got
here
applesauce is pretty nice here this is
the kind of stuff we're talking about
here we've got lots of bottled water too
so no shortage of bottled water you
can't have enough bottled water but it's
it's little snacks like this for the
kids that we're really looking forward
we'll be here live till six o'clock come
on down make a difference have a great
weekend everybody